[موسيقى]
استمرار الهجمات على اراضينا يعني ان ناخذ
المزيد من الاراضي الاوكرانيه وقد اعذر من
انذر رعب يساوي الالمان الرئيس الروسي
يدخل في دبابه الالمانيه وبعد تسلمه
الاسلحه النوويه رئيس بيلاروسيا لن نتردد
في استخدامها اداره بايدن تخطط لامداد
اوكرانيا باسلحه محرمه وبوتين يرد على
الفور واستراتيجيه المانيه جديده وموسكو
هي الهدف والنيتو يعترف بفقدان اسلحته
ويحققه مع وزير الدفاع الاوكراني والرئيس
الجزائري يعلنها من موسكو تخالفنا سيكون
استراتيجيا شاملا
ترحبان بالفرعون المصري كحليف جديد في
مجموعه بريكس ودور اسرائيلي بسبب مصر
والسعوديه وكارثه سوريه مروعه بايادي
تركيه
[موسيقى]
يكشر عن انيابه
اسلحه الغرب تنهال على اوكرانيا من اجل
هدف واحد انه الهجوم المضاد وهو الذي بدات
به قوتك منذ اكثر من اسبوع ليؤكد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان اوكرانيا تشن
هجومها المضاد من اربعه محاور لكن خسائرها
على الجبهه شبه كارثيه وفق قوله ولفت
بوتين الى ان قوات بلاده بتتزع سلاح
اوكرانيا تدريجيا مشيرا الى ان اوكرانيا
فقدت 30% من المركبات التي حصلت عليها من
الغرب في حين خسرت روسيا 54 دبابه مقابل
160 لاوكرانيا هيا لنشاهد المصدر تحدث انه
في خلال هذا الهجوم خسرت اوكرانيا اكثر من
160 دبابه واكثر من 360 مدرعه فقدت وفق
بوتين بالمئه من حجم المعدات التي تسليمها
من الخارج وهو ايضا اعترف بالخسائر التي
منيت بها روسيا في هذه الحرب قال انها
خسرت فقط 54 دبابه ويمكن استعاده بعضها
وقال ان الخسائر البشريه متقاربه بشكل
كبير وهنا فجرها في وجه اوكرانيا وحلفائها
قائلا من روسيا في حال استمر قصف مناطقها
ستنظر في خيار انشاء منطقه عازله على
اراضي اوكرانيا اتدرون ماذا تعني المنطقه
العازله هذا يعني ان بوتين سينتزع اراضي
اوكرانيه جديده ويجعلها منزوعه السلاح
ليضمن ان بلاده بحسب وكاله تازه ليمتد
الخط العازل على طول حدود مقاطعه الفيف مع
اللمبرجر البولنديه وذلك وفق ديمتريديف
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي التهديدات
الروسيه هذه دقه ناقوس الخطر في برلين
وبعد ان استولت القوات الروسيه على العديد
من الاسلحه الغربيه اوكرانيا كتبت صحيفه
بلد الالمانيه ان المقاتلين الروسي
يقاتلون الان على دباباتنا فيما يخشى
الالمان ان يدخل بوتين الى كييف على متن
دبابه المانيه وفق الصحيفه الالمانيه وفي
رد الفعل الامريكي على خساره الاسلحه
الغربيه تتجه اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
وبتوصيه من البنتاجون الى تزويد القوات
الاوكرانيه بقضاءك تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم لمساعدتها في التصدي للدبابات
الروسيه ولتحقيق اكبر قدر ممكن من التقدم
في ساحه المعركه وذلك
لياتي الرد فورا وعلى لسان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين هذه المره والذي قال ان
خسائر روسيا عشر خسائر الطرف المهاجم عدد
بوتين باستخدام اسلحه تحتوي على
اليورانيوم المنضب لو استدعت الضروره ردا
على استخدامها ضد بلاد حسب قوله وكانه
يقول
ودابوها بالتي كانت هي الداء وكالعاده
اليكم المصدر
سار البشريه للجيش
الاوكراني
يعني
[موسيقى]
واجهت بلاده عملا عدوانيا مهلا مهلا مهلا
يا هذا مهلا
بان التحكم بهذه الاسلحه بيدروس وانهم هم
من سيستخدمونه اذن فلماذا تهدد باستخدامها
اليوم ليعود لوكاشينكو ويعبر عن ثقته بان
الغرب سيقلص مساعدتي لاوكرانيا بعد فشل
هجومها المضاد مؤكدا ان الخلا بين
اوكرانيا والدول الغرب قد بدا بالفعل اما
حلف النيتو وبعد كل تلك الخسائر في
اوكرانيا فان بعض اعضاء الحلف يضغطون على
جو بايدن لاسراء بضم اوكرانيا الى النيتو
فيما يندلع نقاش بين الاعضاء حول دعم
المسار الاسرع والاكثر امانا لعضويه
اوكرانيا
فهل سيسمح بايدن باقحام الحلف في صراع
مباشر مع موسكو هذا ما سيتضح خلال الفتره
المقبله اما الامين العام لحلف الناتو
بفقدان قوات معدات واسلحه غربيه مشيرا الى
ان الحلف ينتظر معلومات حول هذا الموضوع
من وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
وها نحن نتصفح المصدر من موقع سبوتنيك
العالمي ليعود ويقول ان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد لا يزال في بداياته ونجاحه سيزيد
القوه التفاوضيه مشيرا الى ان الاوكراني
بحاجه الى امدادات عسكريه مستمره من الحلف
فعن اي امدادات يتحدث علي الامدادات التي
صارت في ايدي القوات الروسيه منها من
العتاد الذي تم دفنه في اوكرانيا ليجيب
الرئيس الفرنسي في مؤتمر صحفي مع المستشار
الالماني والرئيس البولندي ان دوالهم كل
شيء لمساعده الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
مضيفا انه تم تكثيف تسليم الذخائر
والاسلحه والعربات وان ذلك سيتواصل في
الايام والاسابيع المقبله وبرغم الدعم
الغربي المتواصل لقد شبه وزير خارجيه
اوكرانيا
بالدبابه من دون مدفعها من دون وجود اليه
سريعه لضمها فيما قال السفير الروسي في
الولايات المتحده
ان الغرباء لا يدركون انه لن بمقدور اي
كميه من الاسلحه تغيير مسار الحرب غير ان
تلك الاسلحه تدخل الغرب في الصراع مع
روسيا اكثر فاكثر وبالعوده لنتائج هجوم
كييف المضاد فقد اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه
استعاده السيطره على بلده ماكاريفكا ضمن
عمليات هجومها في منطقه دونيسك ومن
اوكرانيا الى موسكو حيث حط الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون رحاله لثلاثه
ايام وذلك استجابه لدعوه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ليعلن رئيس الوزراء الروسي
ميخائيل ميشوستن خلال لقائه تبون ان
التوقيع على اعلان الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين الجانبين يعتبر خطوه هامه
لانتقال مستوى التعاون الى مرحله نوعيه
جديده وموثوقه حسب قوله لننتقل الى
المانيا حيث اعلن المستشار الالماني عن
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الجديده في
البلاد وتتضمن الاستراتيجيه الجديده
اعتبار الخطر الاكبر على السلام في اوروبا
والمحيط الاطلسي فهل بامكان هذه
الاستراتيجيه تغيير شيء على الواقع وبين
هذا وذاق قال السفير الروسي في القاهره
جورج بوريسينكو من مصر قد تقدمت بطلب
للانضمام الى مجموعه لان احدى المبادرات
التي تشارك فيها
تحويل التجاره الى عملات بديله قدر
الامكان سواء كانت وطنيه او انشاء نوع من
العملات المشتركه ومصر مهتمه جدا بهذا
الامر حسب تعبيره
الاحداث والتطورات قال الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغنن بلاده لن توافق على عضويه
السويد في حلف النيتو قبل ايجاد حل لمساله
مكافحه الارهاب بينما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
التركيه تحيد واحد واربعين مسلحا من حزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي بمنطقتي الرفعه ومنبج شماليه سوريه
اعرب الت اعلام عبريه عن مخاوف اسرائيل من
امتلاك مصر والسعوديه اسلحه نوويه بعد
تسجيل ايران لسلاحها النووي مما كشف
نتنياهو عن ان سبب 90% من مشاكل بلاده
تنبع من ايران وفق موقع والا العبري وفره
الاسلحه الغربيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
جعلت من اوكرانيا مقبره لها برايكم الى اي
مدى سيستمر الغرب بمساعدتك عسكريا
[موسيقى]